翻訳: Hideo Tokimatsu
校正: Ai Tokimatsu
今日は このことを
皆さんにお伝えしたいと思うんですけど
日本にはね 実はね
すごく格好良いところが沢山ある
でも日本人も知らなかったりするんですよね
そこを僕は
ぐーっと このパフォーマンスで表現して
世界中で
ショーをしてきた
39ヶ国って すごくないですか
39ヶ国でパフォーマンス したんですけれども
そうでもないみたいですか
（笑）
（拍手と歓声）
行った本人がね
国の名前を数えていて
調子良くて25ぐらいまでしか数えられないんですよ
結構すごかったと思います
なぜこんなことが可能になったのかというところを
今日はお話しします
実はね
日本の伝統文化から
この３つの切り口で 僕は
ぐーっと格好良さだけを抽出して
そしてパフォーマンスに活かしている
格好良さ
動きリズム 精神
まず 動きからいきましょうか
ちょっと動きを見てください
2つの動きをしますから
どちらが空手の動きかということを当てて欲しい
1つ目
なぜここで笑いが起きる？
（笑）
2つ目
どちらが空手の動きでしょうか？
一目瞭然でしょう
誰でもわかるよね
後半が空手の動きです
これね 格闘技に興味のない人でも皆わかる
でも何故？
そこが日本の格好良さが
隠されているところなんです
ボクシングは 実は
すべての各部をひねりながら
パワーを生み出す
腰もツイスト
胸もツイストで
ひねりの動きです
でも 空手はまったく逆
腰まっすぐ前
胸まっすぐ前で
ストレートにエネルギーを出す
逆側の手を「引き手」って言うんですけどね
引いて 体をロックさせる
捻らないことにより
アームをシャープにコントロールすることができる
そして引き手を引くことによって
シャープな動きを
スパーン！と止めることができる
これ格好良くないですか？
これ パフォーマンスに入れない手はないですよね
僕の動き すべてはここから来ているんですね
リズム
リズムというか音の使い方です
日本の文化って
本来 あまり意味のないというものを
「間」と
「間」
「間」と表現して
結構 大切にするんですね
間を外さないようにとか
間を取るとかね
僕が一番注目しているのが これ
一本締めです
一本締めって知っていますよね
「よおー ポン！」っていうやつね
これ日本の方々とやるとビターっと揃う
でも海外でやると これがね
バラバラバラって
短い拍手みたいになるんですよ
不思議でしょう
だって僕ら日本人は
一本締めを一生懸命練習して
できるようになった訳じゃない
普通にできる
一回ここでやってみましょうか
今日ね
外国の方もいらっしゃるので
ちょっと結果が楽しみなんですけど
いきますね
よーお！
（一本締め）
ね！？
（笑）
（拍手）
ありがとうございます
不思議でしょう？
でも これ 海外の方から言わせると
「よーお！」の「お」が終わった後
無音になるでしょう
どこからのタイミングで動き出して
どこからのタイミングで音を出すの？
考えるそうなんですよ
でも僕らは全然考えてない
無音のところをちゃんと
コントロールできているんですね
これを僕はパフォーマンスに入れている
ガーッと音が流れてきて
ピタッと音が止まる
その後 無音なんだけれども
その次に僕が動き出すタイミングと
それから 僕は映像を使うんだけれどね
映像と音が
ピターっと揃う
すると海外では
"Oh, Japanese Cool"
(日本ってカッコイイ）ってなるんですよ
体の動かし方とか リズムのこと
なかなか言葉では伝えられないので
ちょっとパフォーマンスでお見せします
あのパフォーマンスの後 また
お話 少しします
これ言っておかないと
パフォーマンス終わった後で
スゴイ拍手で追い出されるような感じって
（笑）
ね？
まだ続きはありますから すみません
（音楽）
（音楽終わり）
(拍手）
（笑）
I told you.
(言ったでしょう）
Patrick: "Taken it to the whole new level, it isn't, huh?
(別次元に進化したパフォーマンスですね）
ありがとうございます
今 ご覧いただいたパフォーマンスは
武道の「己に勝つ」という
心得を描いたものです
修行をずっと続けると
心の壁が破れてブレイクスルーが起きる
気づくんですね
敵は外にいないって
自分の中にこそ敵はいる
そして自分自身との戦いが始まるという内容です
ちなみに僕の名前「克己」って言います
両親がつけてくれてね
大変感謝しています
（拍手）
最後
先ほどの「己に勝つ」も
精神の格好良さですけれども
もう一つ
どうしても僕が伝えたいものがある
それは武道の中で
一つ面白い考え方があるんですよ
こんなことを知っていますか？
日本の武道って
勝っても喜んではダメなんですよ
おかしいでしょう
だって 勝つために一生懸命
トレーニングしたのに
勝った瞬間
喜んではダメなんです
何故かって
武道は元々
真剣のバトルだった
だから自分が勝ったということは
目の前に負けている相手が
いる訳ですよね
昔の戦いだったら
大けがしてる
もしかしたら命を落としているかもしれない
だから勝った人は
まず相手のことを労わる気持ちを
持ちましょうねっていうのが
勝っても喜んではダメという教えなんです
これは格好良くないですか？
惻隠と言います
惻隠の心とかね
これ実際に 皆さんの携帯で「そくいん」と入れると
この漢字 出てきますよ
これは
アクションを起こす前に
想像して下さいね
相手の立場になって
相手のことを思いやりながら
結果を想像する
それが相手に迷惑をかけたり
嫌な思いをさせるんだったら
アクションする前にやめておきましょう
というのがこの惻隠の心です
これは格好良いなって
日本の武道にはすごく格好良い
これがあるんだなあと思ったけれども
違っていた
これ実はね 日本人全員が
根底に持っているものなんですよ
何で気づいたかというと
震災の後です
被災された方々が
水の配給を待つ時に
一列になって それをずっと並んで順番を待っている
それをね
海外のメディアはこぞって取材して
自分たちの国に発信していた
ニュースとしてね
でも僕たちからすると
そんなニュースになることでもないなと思っている
なぜかというと自分のことを よく考えてみると
例えば家が流されて
家族を失って
のどがカラカラ
だからといって人を押しのけて
水を取ろうとは思わない
だって前に並んでる人も多分そうなんだろうな
後ろの人だって もっと酷いかもしれない
まず相手の立場になって
相手のことを思いやるから
その心が自然に１つのラインにつながるんですよ
僕 これに気づいた時にね
これこそ
Japanese Coolだと思ったんですよ
めちゃくちゃ格好良いなって
これを僕は目標にしている
惻隠をパフォーマンスで表現する
世界中に伝えたい
だってアクションを起こす前に
相手の身になって考えてくださいね
こんな考えがあるってことを知るだけで もう
人は変わると思う
僕はパフォーマンスで表現していくから
今ここで初めて知った皆さんは
たくさんの方に
日本って惻隠っていうのがあるらしいよ
って伝えて欲しいです
2020年に向かって
海外から たくさんお客さんが
いらっしゃるじゃないですか
聞かれると思うんですよ
ねーねーねー
日本の良いところってどこなの？って
皆さん 個人個人が多分
日本の良いところをお持ちだと思うんですけれども
そこの中の一つに
ぜひこの惻隠を
加えていただけたらなと思います
ありがとうございました
（拍手）